so what kind of interesting classes are
there
yeah i mean you could have just maybe
say what are the
if you you take any kind of computer
science class what are the classes you
learn
good let me let me tell you sort of the
the the biggest ones the ones that you
would learn first
so you know first of all there is p
that's what it's called
okay it stands for polynomial time and
this is just the class of
all of the problems that you could solve
with a conventional computer
like your iphone or your laptop uh you
know by a completely deterministic
algorithm
right using a number of steps that grows
only like the size of the input raised
to some fixed
power okay so uh if your algorithm is
linear time
like you know for adding numbers okay
that that problem is in p
if you have an algorithm that's
quadratic time like the
elementary school algorithm for
multiplying two numbers that's also in p
even if it was the size of the input to
the 10th power
or to the 50th power well that wouldn't
be very uh good in practice
but you know formally we would still
count that that would still be in p
okay but if your algorithm takes
exponential time
meaning like if every time i add one
more
uh data point to your input if the
time that needed by the algorithm
doubles if you need time like two to the
power
of the amount of input data then uh
that is that we call an exponential time
algorithm
okay and that is not polynomial okay so
p
is all of the problems that have some
polynomial time algorithm
okay so that includes most of what we do
with our computers on a day-to-day basis
you know
all the you know sorting basic
arithmetic
you know whatever is going on in your
email reader or in angry birds
okay it's all in p then the next uh
super important class is called np
that stands for non-deterministic
polynomial
okay does not stand for not polynomial
which is a
common confusion um but np was basically
all of the problems
where if there is a solution then it is
easy to check the solution
if someone shows it to you okay so
actually a perfect example of a problem
in
np is uh factoring the one i told you
about before
like if i gave you a number with
thousands of digits
and i told you that it you know i i
asked you
does this uh does this have at least um
three non-trivial divisors right that
might be a super hard problem to solve
right might take you millions of years
using any algorithm that's known at
least running
on our existing computers okay but if i
simply showed you the divisors
i said here are three divisors of this
number
then it would be very easy for you to
ask your computer
to just check each one and see if it
works just divide it in see if there's
any remainder
right and if they all go in then you've
checked well i guess there were
right so um so any problem
where you know wherever there's a
solution there is a short
witness that can be easily like a
polynomial size
witness that can be checked in
polynomial time
that we call an np problem okay
and uh yeah so so every problem that's
in p
is also in np right because you know you
could always just ignore the witness and
just
you know if a problem is in p you can
just solve it yourself right okay but
now
the enzymes as the central you know
mystery of theoretical computer science
is is every np
problem in p so if you can easily check
the answer to
a a computational problem does that mean
that you can also easily find the answer
even though there's all these problems
that appear to
be very difficult to find the answer
it's still an open question whether
a good answer exists so what's yours no
one has proven that there's no way to do
it it's
arguably the most uh
i don't know the most famous the most
maybe interesting maybe you disagree
with that
problem in theoretical computer science
so what's your most famous for sure
p equals np yeah if you were to bet all
your money
where do you put your money that's an
easy one p is not equal to n p okay so i
i
like to say that if we were physicists
we would have just declared that to be a
law of nature
you know just like just like
thermodynamics it's hilarious
giving ourselves nobel prizes for its
discovery yeah you know and look
if later if later it turned out that we
were wrong we just give ourselves
more books more nobel prizes yeah uh
i mean you know but yeah because we're
so harsh but
i mean no i mean i mean i mean it's it's
really just because we are
mathematicians
or descended from mathematicians you
know we have to call things conjectures
that other people would just call
empirical facts or discoveries
right okay so but one shouldn't read
more into that difference in in language
you know about the underlying truth so
okay so you're a good investor
and good spender money so then let me
know i don't know that let me ask
another way
is it possible at all
and what would that look like if p
indeed equals np
well i do think that it's possible i
mean in fact you know when people really
pressed me on my blog for what odds
would i put
well you know two or three percent odds
wow that's pretty good that p
equals np yeah just be well um because
you know when peop
i mean i mean you really have to think
about like if there were
50 you know mysteries like p versus np
and if i made a guess about every single
one of them
would i expect to be right 50 times
right and the truthful answer is no
okay yeah so you know and and and and
and that's what you really mean in
saying that you know you have
you know better than 98 odds for
something okay but
um so so yeah you know i mean there
could certainly be surprises and look
if p equals np well then there would be
the further question
of you know is the algorithm actually
efficient in practice
you